it is serious and it is highly unusual
as well to have a charge of treason it
all goes back to Christmas day of 2021
the queen was spending Christmas at
Windsor Castle it was as we now know to
be her last Christmas she was waiting
for members of the family to gather at
the castle when just after eight o'clock
jazz fan seeing child was arrested and
found in the grounds of the castle it's
thought he'd used a nylon rope ladder to
scale and out of fence and make his way
inside he told police officers at the
scene I am here to kill the queen he was
reportedly wearing a mask and a hood and
carrying this crossbow which was loaded
with a bolt and with the safety catch
off off now just moments before he was
arrested we understand he posted a video
to around 20 people explaining how he
had this intention to assassinate 8. the
queen and today from Broadmoor hospital
he pleaded guilty to all of those three
charges the most serious under the
treason act of 1842 of attempting to
injure or alarm The Sovereign also
pleaded guilty to a second charge of
possession of an offensive weapon and a
third charge of making threats to kill
he spoke today only to confirm his name
and to enter those guilty pleas and he
will be sentenced we understand on the
31st of March like I say treason is
really unusual the last time someone was
jailed for treason was back in 1981 it
was Marcus sergeant and he was found
guilty after firing blanks at the queen
during trooping the color but this whole
case has raised some wider issues
firstly the availability of offensive
weapons like crossbows and also one
about the security of members of the
royal family how was it that a member of
the public could make their way into the
grounds of Windsor Castle carrying a
weapon that was loaded with the intent
as he said to kill the queen